exponential growth in the clay is a very
very brief topic I my plan system three
four days because number one all the
questions you will face on this topic
are very similar to each other okay
so unlike say different induction right
even though you have to go through the
same steps always different varieties of
induction which almost apart from the
actual method reduction they don't share
much to do with each other
you saw one and if you see another one
which is a different style you almost
not even sure where to start with it
they're all these little tricks like
factorials and divisibility and trig and
calculus they're all really different
right exponential revenue can almost all
the questions you look at variables just
capture the different language okay
words secondly you've got all the tools
you need to do this topic already in
fact I could always just give you the
questions and in terms of
differentiating integrating subbing and
doing problem solving you guys can do it
already but I'm just going to walk you
through the wording for these questions
and then essentially and have a look at
some harder examples later okay so
what's the idea of exponential growth in
okay before we get to this idea the
exponential idea right I want to think
about okay things that grow and things
that shrink okay in nature so in fact
sometimes this is not called exponential
revenue K sometimes it's called natural
growth than K some textbooks and some
syllabus is call it that okay
what are some things that get big up and
get smaller in nature okay things like
say the population okay or bacteria or
something like that
things like say radioactive sources
which the the idea of radioactivity is
that it's giving off matter in the form
of energy right so as it's giving things
off that means itself it's getting
smaller okay so I'm filling up bigger
its decay okay
the idea behind these things is that the
bigger the thing is okay
the bigger the thing is the faster it
grows or decays
does that make sense I'm gonna I'm
trying to get a really intuitive
definition of this for you before I give
you the technical one because people see
the technical one they like I know what
it means okay so the biggest something
is the faster it grows or decays okay so
let's the air populations right the
bigger population is the more people
within it can actually have children in
that kind of thing so the bigger
population gets the faster you can grow
does that make sense and starts off
really really slow that's okay starts
off really slow and then as the
population gets larger okay that's why
we've got this exponential shape so
that's why it's called exponential
growth and education in the same way the
more of a radioactive substance you've
got okay the more atoms there are that
are giving off this radiation okay more
radiation means it's losing quantities
of mass faster okay the less there is
the slower goes so instead of this kind
of scenario you've got a doing this and
it's approaching some other kind of
quantity down below here until it
vanishes okay
so because something is the fatter grows
or decays that's just the common sense
definition here's a more technical one
okay the rate of change so this is the
growth or decay part something's getting
bigger as well the rate of change is
proportional to
the quantity of whatever you have okay
so if the quantity of our population is
larger okay that means that the rheya
which is changing is proportionately
larger okay so for instance the idea is
if you got ten people and that
population is growing okay and you have
50 people and that population is also
growing we would say you know that the
population of 50 is going not just
growing but it's going five times faster
than the population of twenty says this
proportionality is here okay all right
now when you think about rates of change
okay we're talking about differentiation
which I've meant derivatives okay where
is the quantity what you've got
that's the original or primitive
function that you got your own rate of
change from right okay so we're saying
that a derivative and its function are
in proportion to each other okay
so how do we write proportionality you
have two ways you can say a there's
actually a symbol for proportionality it
looks kind of like an alpha in fact I
write it like an alpha when you typeset
it looks slightly different you could
say a is proportional to B okay
or if you remember think back to you 10
and when we did variation as a topic ok
direct variation in direct variation
rather than using this wiener really
simple ok this is actually equivalent to
saying a is equal to K B so a and B they
grow at the same rate where they shrink
at the same rate but there's this
constant in here okay because it's the
constant that tells you how much bigger
or smaller one thing is than the other
we call it the constant of
proportionality okay so really this
statement and this statement I
equivalent ok
but in order to do calculus and that
kind of thing we're gonna go with this
one rather than this one okay it just
makes things easier to write now well
I've seen I am free here ok we said
these they're these two things are
proportional okay
but we know what the two things are
there an original function and what you
get after you differentiate the function
okay so let's try and take this and
rather have a and be able to general
then it refer anything specific okay how
would we write them in terms of the
language of the terminology we already
know okay we usually call functions like
yes right so you'd say f of X will that
it be equal to the constant of
proportionality multiplied by the
derivative of the function that's gonna
give you the rate of change okay so you
could write it like this if you like
okay sometimes we may call the functions
f another common name for function is
like why write y equals some X blah blah
blah so we could say y equals K Y - okay
or okay times that's it should actually
be a okay cuz it's a rate of change over
time yeah okay
now think again and I know the name of
the topic sort of spoiled it right but
what kind of function behaves like this
right what kind of function do you have
when you differentiate it you get
something very similar identical to it
but it's it's off by some kind of
proportion right and the answer is an
exponential function hence the name of
the topic okay so what you'll find the
most commonly written is let Y or the
other common name is paid for population
okay let equal a to the KT okay now when
you take the derivative of it dy on duty
what's it equal to given that these two
other letters a okay I just constant T's
that variable what's the derivative okay
okay so this is an extensional tensor
chain rule right so that K is going to
come out the front out of the and that's
the inside function is through it and
then the rest of it it just stays the
way it is because that's what happens
when you're differentiate so you can see
from this slide here then it's obeying
mm-hmm we call it why it's obeying this
proportionality thing it doesn't matter
which side you've got the K on that just
means it's a constant I can flip the
constant over but it would still be a
constant okay but this ID here of that
the rate of change and the quantity of
what's changing they are in proportion
okay
that's why the exponential function is
what we're dealing with okay